hold on here diapers because the rugrats
is
coming back rugrats was nickelodeon's
smash hit of the 90s in addition to 172
episodes
the show also spawned a 300 million
dollar movie franchise
19 video games and celeb fans everywhere
so who's your favorite character
tommy and baby dylan why
because my name is dylan have you ever
had celebrities
come up to you and say oh i love rugrats
yeah alec baldwin
and so sweet because yeah everybody just
kind of humbles out when you talk about
rugrats
streaming now on paramount plus all the
faves are back
though their adventures now take place
in 2021
even with a 17-year break it was easy
for the voice actors to get
back in the groove it's just like riding
a bicycle
baby please clean this chick wheel like
this
of course nancy cartwright will be back
to pulling double duty voicing chucky on
rugrats and continuing to voice bart on
the simpsons
nancy how would chucky and bart simpson
get along
nobody's ever asked me that bart simpson
like i'm 10 years old man i'm 10.
i don't think bart would be hanging with
chucky it's so
[Music]
hard